the Joe Rogan experience so the last few
weeks we've been getting these annoying
text messages from re where everything's
in Spanish everything everything no what
is this how long is this joke gonna go
that's guerrilla and then he gets here
with a backpack on like where you been I
was in Medellin he was he was doing you
were doing a Spanish immersion thing
yeah a hundred percent Spanish I brought
back these Cuban cigars Wow duh so the
Columbia did you have any Spanish
speaking lessons before you went to
Colombia cero
yeah sounds like zero it does how a lot
of its are pretty close so no I had
nothing
cero is zero yeah yo hablo espanol
tambien alright yeah you also do in a
podcast yeah yeah this is me jackpot
party like when when Tom gets me to in
America is gonna go run the escape plan
right now this conversation there's a
term lateen X which is not Latino or
latina it's you know it's just a
gender-neutral way of saying like yeah
yeah with cousin in Spanish you know to
sabe latina he's like oh ma Rico I'm
like you know it's a gender-neutral so
you're saying he was like a [ __ ] what
I'm saying
my teacher we were talking about like
parents thumb like that there was like
the word for parents it's just like
fathers pretty much yeah so then it's
like what if you have two mothers do you
call it madres as parents instead of
like you know if it's just fathers Padre
but just mother it's Madre but if it's
parents is my Padres great so I'm like
do it's just a gate and they're like she
was like no still Padres and then you
know that's okay these days
could be like that's fine though
yeah what country do you think is most
in the dark ages with woke miss rut
Russia oh yeah yeah Russia they they
make laws about gas they they did oil
for the Olympics Iran has a corn to
their leader zero percent homosexual
population Yeah right
worse than in Russia because Russia has
people that are outside of the control
of the government that are just freely
speaking that are talking about
homosexual problems and like [ __ ] Riot
remember one [ __ ] while I was getting a
lot of [ __ ] yeah they're [ __ ] on it
you like that yeah I got to think about
that no at all you know like your
there's a kind of a selling like point
from them that that it's they're trying
to be progressive thinkers like some of
them will like disguise it as that but
they're definitely they're not [ __ ]
around so Russia some government agency
made it tweet about freedom of the press
what they say about respecting
respecting the press and we're spent
appreciating the press and someone some
journal said this is a country that has
literally like this administration has
literally been responsible for the
murders of dozens of people that are
that are journalists yeah like when
people would report on them or people
with running running against certain
members of the government yes welcome
for sure daylight and even more
disappearances which is slang for
murders yeah you know that person is
just gone we haven't seen we're just
displaying it so I don't know I can't
wait to go back and see how much it's
changed like you're going back yeah
doing a tour there for sure what kids
like we want to go to I was like fun
facts but yeah but guys and ask them
questions that I asked when I was in
college like I remember asking him about
black people and they were like oh no no
no they don't
that way they can't be here Roy Jones
jr. is a Russian citizen no like a legit
Russian citizen this was 1995
yes Roy Jones jr. has been going on with
Russia for a long time he's a giant star
over there they love him there were
fights here Oh totally serious I'm
thinking of Roy woods yeah Roy Jones jr.
with Putin
it looks like Putin's shaking his hand
too hard he's trying to get it away mmm
maybe perhaps I don't think so but he's
over there all the time he's got a
[ __ ] Russian passport [ __ ] I'd like
that listen dude they threw that triple
a poon Ana at him yeah strip away a
Russian kunana that's that smiling I'm
smiling yeah yeah he knows he's fought
over there a bunch of times too far over
there fairly recently how long did it be
there for bright no I just like two
weeks maybe I don't know it's yeah yes
he shows yeah mmm excited shows there
who did Andrew Schultz yeah yeah yeah he
put it on put some of it on Manos I bet
Gaffigan has two he's done shows [ __ ]
everywhere every wasn't it already plays
more places in gym game yeah he just
announced that he's doing a Latin
American tour it was [ __ ] in English
yeah of course he goes everywhere
everywhere
[Applause]